back
here some Scholars say that smoking is
Haram I'd like to know what's your
opinion and does smoking invalidate the
fast as far as smoking is
concerned several years before when
science had an advanced that far most of
the scholars used to say that smoking is
Mak based on the of wasallam which is
mentioned s bukari Vol number one in the
book of Adan Hadith number 855 where the
Prophet said that anyone who eats garlic
or onion they should stay away from us
and stay away from the mosque Prophet
said that you know don't come to the
mosque after having garlic onion because
there's bad breath when you are smoking
the breath is worse than an So based on
this Hadi therefore garlic and doesn't
become Haram it Mak So based on this
Hadith Scholars give the fwa that
smoking is Mak but now after science has
advanced we have come to know that
smoking is nothing but it's a slow
poisoning tobacco in any
form whether smoking cigarettes whether
Bey with tobacco in hookah whether
chewing tobacco all forms of tobacco
contains nicotin and tar and we know
it's nothing but slow poisoning that is
the reason most of
the non-muslims also they agree that
smoking is Haram not only the Muslim
world even the non-muslims that's the
reason they put a statutory warning on
the cigarette packs they put a statutary
warning saying cigarette smoking is
injured to health or in some countries
it mentioned general surgeons warning or
surgeon generals warning smoking is
injurious to health and anyone gives the
ad whether newspaper in the magazine or
television it is complet that they have
to highlight the statement smoking is
injurious to health so I'm talking about
the Muslim world even the non-muslim
world agrees that smoking is nothing but
slow
poisoning and today according to
statistics the World Health Organization
says that every year more than 4 million
people die only because of smoking and
if you count the other forms of tobacco
it will be much more and Today Medical
Science Tas and even I learned when I
was doing my medicine in the Medical
College
that more than
90% of the lung cancer deaths are only
due to smoking whether cigarette or bed
whatever it is 25% of the cardiovascular
deaths are only because of
smoking 70 to 75% of
bronchitis and related deaths are only
because of smoking smoking is nothing
but slow poisoning it blackens your lips
blackens your gums your fingertips it
damages your lips it damages your
esophagus it damages your stomach and it
can cause constipation it can cause a
loss of appetite it can cause loss of
libido or sexual power gets suppressed
it can cause
immunity to the drugs you take and it
reduces the defense of your body and you
can only give a talk on why smoking is
Haram and I've given a talk on dryy laws
in Islam and I've covered this topic in
detail time doesn't permit me here but
based on all these various research
there are today more than 400 fatwas the
majority of the scholars they agree that
smoking is Haram and all form of tobacco
is Haram there may be certain Scholars
of certain countries including this
country where I come from India they say
it is Mak yet but most of the scholars
otherwise throughout the world majority
of them they agree that smoking is Haram
Allah says in the Quran in Surah chapter
number 7 verse number 157 that you
follow the Prophet The unlettered
Prophet who's mentioned in your law in
scriptures and further it says that this
Prophet asks you to do things which are
good for you t for
you so take what he gives it to you what
is lawful and good and he prohibits
things which are things which are
unlawful things which are bad for you so
what a prophet gives what he gives you
which is good take and he prohibits you
things which areab unlawful you have to
abstain from it this is a and and Allah
says in the Quran in Surah Bak chapter
number two verse number
195 make not your own hands the cause of
your own destruction indicating that do
not kill your own self because smoking
is nothing but so poisoning it come
under this category something like
suicide slow poisoning every puff you
take you reduce your life so based on
this there are more than 400 fatwas
saying that smoking is Haram and
furthermore this is one of the major
reason why it's Haram further Allah
says in the Quran in Surah chapter
number 7 verse number 31 eat and drink
but do not be
extravagant Allah says in Sur is chapter
number 17 verse number 26 27 that do not
be extravagant do not be a spendthrift
for verily a person who a spend Thrift
is a brother of the Satan is a brother
of the devil and we know that when we
smoke it's nothing but extravagance it's
nothing but taking a pound note or a few
pounds or taking a dollar note the green
dollar bill or a pound and lighting up
with fire when we smoke when we light
the cigarette it's nothing but burning
money whether it be rupees whether it be
dollars whether it be pounds whether it
be real it's nothing but extra vag which
is Haram in Islam and you can give a
list of reasons why it's Haram but just
to cut it short one more reason that you
cannot harm your own neighbor you cannot
harm your own
brother and in smoking when you exhale
out the smoke it causes more damage to
your neighbor passive smoking is more
dangerous than active smoking and the
person who smokes when he exhales out if
the person who a neighbor inhales the
smoke it causes more damage to him than
the person who smokes that's the reason
many countries like Singapore Etc they
banned smoking in public places in your
personal hous you can do it in public
places in government places smoking has
been banned So based on this it's Haram
so smoking is Haram as far as the second
part of the question is concerned that
does smoking invalidate the fast
normally when a person smokes the smoke
goes into the lung but there are some
other particles
also that goes into the stomach so when
you smoke besides the smoke going into
the lungs it also goes into the stomach
and there are some particles there are
some Leal things so all the scholars
unanimously agree that smoking does
break the fast it invalidates the fast
so when you're smoking besides a person
breaking the fast he's even doing a sin
and and that reduces the reward and many
people who are change smokers they don't
smoke during fasting but the moment the
fast ends after they take Puffs and they
keep on smoking the full night and this
again defeats the purpose of fasting
increasing a tawa and if a person can
abstain from
dawn to dusk from the beginning of dawn
to Sunset very well he can abstain from
smoking from the CR to the Grave so it's
my advice the chain smoker Ramadan is a
very good time where they can really
stop smoking and that will be a
permanent part in the life inshallah for
the future